aber ich möchte ein thema vorstellen was
mich bewegt und zwar ist es die
energiepreis explosion die uns drohen
könnte deswegen mein thema die
energiepreis explosion sie muss nämlich
verhindert werden deutschland legte
putin pipeline nord stream 2 auf eis und
russland baut sofort ein schreck
szenario auf russlands ex präsident
dmitri medwedew in europa die angst vor
explodierenden energiepreisen naja es
gibt ja so viel sagt am dienstag bei
twitter zitat herzlich willkommen in
einer neuen welt wo die europäer bald
schon 2000 euro pro 1000 kubikmeter gas
zahlen werden das bedeutet im klartext
der präsident der ex präsident spricht
von einem möglichen verdopplung der
gaspreise für die kunden in europa stand
jetzt ist es so dass 10.000 kubikmeter
gas kostet im ford in der eu rund 900
euro die deutsche politik muss jetzt
endlich aufwachen wir dürfen uns nicht
noch stärker in die abhängigkeit von
russland begeben die harte wahrheit ist
aktuell sind wir abhängig aber wir
müssen jetzt mit vollgas in alternative
energieträger investiert kurzfristig
atomkraft langfristig wasserstoff aber
jetzt bin ich froh dazu die meinung von
meinem kollegen voran zimmer zu haben
janina ich geb dir vollkommen recht wir
hätten schon längst viel unabhängiger
werden müssen vom russischen gas und das
ist ein scheitern der deutschen politik
in den vergangenen 20 jahren angefangen
mit gerhard schröder und dem architekten
der gesamten russischen außenpolitik das
war frank walter steinmeier der heutige
bundespräsident dann ging es weiter mit
angela merkel mit olaf scholz alle
wollten daran festhalten dass wir eben
keine alternativen finden und man hat
bis zuletzt basterds verzweifelung als
an nordstream zwei sich geklammert
obwohl klar war dass wenn wir uns
abhängig machen von russischem gas wie
erpressbar sind
wie sehen sie das wenn wir hier mal in
die hunde fragen bei das doppel zwischen
den beiden herren ein wenig auflösen was
würden sie sagen wir in der zukunft frau
sei bei damit umgehen mit den steigenden
energiepreisen auch mit blick auf die
russlandkrise also ich halte atomkraft
für keine wirklich veritable lösung weil
sie haben durch einen guten zwischen
vorschlag gemacht wir brauchen eine
übergangslösung das ist nicht einfach
also wenn ich meine ece fahrer dann sehe
ich ja sowieso
immer wieder und immer öfter große
paneelen felder große flächen die jetzt
neu genutzt werden ich glaube aber
tatsächlich ist ist eine wichtige sache
dass wir in alternative energien
investieren ich mache mir sorgen um die
wälder hier in europa weil das einfach
immer mehr wälder gibt wo dann plötzlich
ganz viele windparks hineingesetzt
werden zum beispiel der wunderschöne
reinhardswald in hessen ich wohne ja in
hessen das ist ein märchenwald da gibt
es viele alte buch und viele eichen und
ich als naturliebhaberin macht mir dann
wirklich sorgen um diese alten wälder
auch wenn ich natürlich grundsätzlich
für alternative energieträger und
energiequellen bin weiß ich nicht wie
wird weitermachen also ich bin muss
ehrlich sagen ein bisschen ratlos es
gibt nicht so wirklich die königs lösung
naja es ist eine schwierige situation
ich möchte zur pause scheinbar jetzt
keine persönlichen worte richten aber
erweitern also natürlich haben wir uns
von russland energietechnisch abhängig
gemacht hatte recht so wie wir uns von
den saudis abhängig gemacht haben und so
wie wir uns von den amerikanern abhängig
gemacht haben wenn man also einen
energieautarken kontinent haben will
dann wird man sich auf diesem kontinent
etwas über den letzten jahren aus
amerika importiert würden weiß jetzt
noch teurer als außen tragen es ist ja
auch lars seite mit wer es gesagt hat
das kostet das doppelte in wahrheit wenn
die europäer dazu bereit sind den preis
zu zahlen es ist darüber zu diskutieren
auch im hinblick auf die ganze
klimawandel debatte um den umstieg auf e
mobilität was das am ende bedeutete und
am ende bedeutet dass in wahrheit und
aufpasst zielt alles ab die ukraine
debatte es ziemlich die klimawandel
debatte es zielt auf die renaissance der
atomkraft ab und das sollten wir uns
nicht in den sack lügen ich bin dagegen
der atomkraft den wir österreicher haben
ein eigenes problem mit der atomkraft
wir haben ein atomkraftwerk das nie in
betrieb genommen wurde weil es durch
eine volksabstimmung
sprichwörtlich versenkt wurde aber was
bedeuten die begehrlichkeiten der grünen
in der deutschen bundesregierung das
erst jeder ford nun in zukunft mit dem
e-auto feinstaub gibt es deswegen doms
oder rechtecke die grünen england
enderich weil sie können sich auch nur
dieses eine konzentrieren die grünen das
ist ihr einziges verdienst dass ihnen
der rest bis heute egal
was bedeutet dass die der umstieg der
gesamten flotte auf mobilität es
bedeutet am ende die abhängigkeit
russland für uns heimat reich die
abhängigkeit füge ich hinzu saudis und
amerika es bedeutete am ende die
renaissance der atomkraft
ob das im sinne des erfinders wagen also
die zweifel und gesagt mit also nur
kurzfristig ich bin davon überzeugt dass
wir jetzt extrem für die forschung
investieren müssen um den energieträger
wasserstoff
zukunftssicher zu machen dass der auch
uns in der zukunft helfen wird
kurzfristig ich gebe ihnen vollkommen
um energie viel zu schneider x naja
achtung ich bin 1986 durfte ich drei
monate nicht in einem sandkasten denn
weil tschernobyl in die luft gegangen
ist und wir durften monate lang eine
schwarze messen bild wie verleger nennt
sich das in deutschland damit mich alle
verstehen also ich habe aber auch so
kojima erlebt also ich hab schon einen
etwas anderen zugang wir werden in
österreich bedroht durch den berlin
durch christo die steht auf
erdbebenlinie sun schrottreaktoren wenn
es eine sichere technologie gibt und
dort treffen wir uns beide wieder das
bedeutet wenn die technologie und die
wissenschaft voranschreitet und uns eine
sichere und saubere energieform bietet
wieder erste terios ich finde aber wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dass es eine
frage der aufmerksamkeit lenkung ist
also bei den salzburger festspielen bei
der eröffnung 2020 da gab es neben der
eröffnungsveranstaltung eine riesige
demonstration von den sogenannten
indigenen dass österreichs also
salzburger umland die demonstriert wie
gegen keine energie trasse und kein
medium ist drauf gegangen ja also die
kameras waren gerichtet auch die tollen
gäste in ihren roben und das ist die
salzburger festspielen losgehen und frau
rabl stadler und so weiter das war alles
wunderbar aber geht die eigentlich so
wichtig auch in sachen energiewende
vollkommen durch die aufmerksamkeit
verdient hält werden und wo es auch
möglich gebrannt hat da hat keine kamera
das auge aufgerichtet und da ist die
frage wie wir mit der energiepolitik
vorankommen wenn wir nicht auch gucken
dass wir medial das auge in die richtige
richtung lenken also dann wäre jetzt
sogar mal einigung am tisch die
abhängigkeit muss weniger werden ich
würde gerne noch ein wenig meiner seine
zeit nutzung der paul noch eine frage zu
stellen die mich sehr interessiert und
zwar abschließend zum ukraine komplex
auch heute abend wie schätzt du einen
was joe biden heute gesagt hat er hat ja
eine rede gehalten und hat dort ja auch
auf 19 2
was erwarten wir von dem amerikanischen
präsident oder was können wir auch als
deutscher in den nächsten wochen
erwarten monaten
ich glaube das war eine klare antwort
des us präsidenten aber nichts was
wladimir putin beeindruckend würde denn
er weiß genau was der westen tut der hat
jeden schritt genau voraus geplant so
scheint es zumindest und ich glaube
nicht dass er sich von dem in
irgendeiner form beeindrucken lässt ich
glaube er wird weiter das tun was er
bereits in den vergangenen 24 stunden in
den vergangenen tagen gemacht hat er
wird fakten schaffen und das dramatische
für die menschen in der ukraine ist für
diejenigen die einen ukrainischen staat
behalten wollen und das ist die ganz
ganz große mehrheit für die bedeutet ist
dass sie auf sich allein gestellt denn
joe biden hat gesagt es wird ein
amerikaner kein nato-soldat ihr
eingesetzt werden die ukraine ist nicht
teil der nato insofern muss man ganz
klar sagen die menschen die 2014 dann
für ihre freiheit gekämpft haben sie
sind auch jetzt bei einer sehr
wahrscheinlichen weiteren aggressions
russlands auf sich alleine gestellt